we're going to do a voicemail sound good
sure let's hear it Sona yes okay punch
it hey Conan I've never listened to the
podcast before but I want to know what
your soft game is like if you have one
drawer that's got like veiny socks with
patterns on them and another drawer
that's got like black and brown socks or
you like put them in the same drawer or
you don't even mess with some kinds of
socks or you will sock during the winter
like just what's your sock game all
right thicker
wow I've never heard the podcast I want
to call that out because I think the
only way to call in is if you listen to
the podcast so this person's yanking
your chain this guy's playing with my
sock is what he's got oh he is you know
I'm gonna say
um let's assume let's take him at his
word he sounds very casual unless he's
trying super hard to be casual he might
be a huge fan who's laying it on thick
like uh I don't really listen to the
broadcast that means he's listened to
everyone twice right and some of them
like this I don't know I think he's
really high I think he's at home eating
some Doritos and he's like I'm gonna
call Conan O'Brien yeah and then he just
Googled how to call you I think that's
true yeah I'm gonna go with that all
right that seems like the most likely
scenario what's his name again he didn't
say he didn't say a name wow he is
pretty chill yeah all right I'm gonna
call him Chill Zone Chill Zone just for
lack of a real name Chill Zone that's a
good question is it
you know it isn't
I'm going to say that was muscle memory
so you've been busted on all fronts yeah
you are a rude Stoner which is a very
odd combination I've never listed your
podcast
screw you man I'm so high it's not
usually how people come across when
they're stoned but anyway I will reveal
how I do it I have two drawers you do I
do have two drawers man what an
aristocrat
when I was a child getting hand-me-downs
from Luke and Neil that didn't fit I
dreamed of not one sock drawer of my own
but two one has all athletic socks
because as you know Sona oh no I work
out constantly
don't just get a body like mine you have
to be in an accidental I was gonna slam
myself but you didn't trust me to do it
and then I have one that has is All
Purpose like some wool socks some of
those Gold Toe socks classic that are
still left over from my late night days
wow because that's the I never went out
and bought gold toe socks but that was
the ones that were assigned to me and
like TBS NBC these socks go back
thousands of years so you stole them no
from the networks you can't steal socks
they just end up being transferred uh
from one place to the other that's
National Broadcasting Company property
that you're you know true story all the
suits I wore all those years at NBC they
were very careful about if I wore them
on the weekend or something to an event
they would want that back on Monday oh I
used to kind of wonder about it because
I'm 6'4 with very specific measurements
and I thought these suits aren't really
gonna fit anybody else I have legs that
are my body is disproportionate I'm a
very large person what are they going to
be doing with these suits and they told
me extras wear them in scenes it's
Saturday night you're kidding me so
whenever you see a six foot four really
long-legged background person on an SNL
sketch they might be wearing a vintage
Conan O'Brien's suit but think about
that from the 90s and 2000s actors were
probably very nervous because they want
to be actors and they're just in the
background sweating all day and night in
that thing and then you're Monday
morning
oh no they wouldn't go no no during the
show after I was done with them no no it
wasn't like I had you turned them in so
that on the weekends
in my defense I was only half listening
I have a question about your socks yeah
do you fold them into each other or do
you lay them flat to save the elasticity
of them now I've got it I lay one on top
of the other and then fold okay yeah
that's how I do it too but some people
are very big on saving the elastic I'm
not I just I don't care if they get a
little loose and floppy it just makes me
look like a a real cool dude it does
yeah what floppy stuff yeah every now
and then I like to show a little like to
show a little ankle you know I'm very
Victorian about my sexuality every now
and then I want someone to just catch a
little bit of my ankle and go I'm
intrigued
you know there was a time when people
showed a lot less and you had to use
your imagination in Victorian era people
used to say like oh look at hmm that
upper collar our bone that's where the
phrase put your best foot forward comes
from showing off your your ankle and
your calf oh really from the restoration
days yes it does yeah that's true that's
great yeah
I didn't know how to react in a culture
where only your eyes are seen if you're
completely covered except your eyes
people are like wow showing a little
lash today yeah you know that I mean it
can be taken to any extreme yeah yeah I
think we are losing
um our sense of True sensuality by
showing too much and I'm trying to bring
it back by covering as much of my body
as possible and that's by popular
requests you just wear a sheet with a
hole or your Winger sticks out
my Wanger
it's the Wanger guy the Winger coming
down the street it sounds like it's a
red hot sounds like a failed car from
the late 70s it's the Ducks and Wanger
it goes 35 miles per hour at top speed
we'll come up with these your Wanger I
don't know I mean that's yeah you know
what you're a guy it's dirty from like
1952. I know this guy was arrested on
Fifth and Elm for showing his wanger
his Straw Hat has been confiscated and
he's being confined in a 1932 Nash
Rambler until he apologizes
I don't I honestly don't know what's
ever going to come out of your mouth
well anyway why use a standard term when
you could make a new one you know what I
mean well I thought that might be one
that you use is Wayne does anybody use
Winger Wang is a term for tadger todger
oh gosh Jesus oh my God for drinks and
berries for your Ghoulies for you know
unbelievable well you're just a font of
this mishmash I love it I think you're a
time traveler sometimes I think that you
know those romantic shows where a guy is
traveling through time and he has a
passionate love in the in the present
day but what's it called oh are you uh
Outlander yeah oh he's like a guy from
Outlander except he's just picking up
different euphemisms from penis
throughout different times and then
coming home to his true love in Pasadena
and saying uh would you like to see my
todger my Wanger I'll be the Velvet
scepter's home you want to see my Winkle
Vibe
I'm here with the old deadly squats you
know you guys are bringing these terms
back so that's cool that's really cool
yeah that's you know well I hope I I do
have I I don't popular would you say
that I'm an extravagant person no I
would not I'm not but I do have two sock
drawers and I think that answers the
question listen if you can have two
I think everybody would want to be able
to have two sock drawers yeah but
because I have two my son has no drawers
at all yeah yeah we had to take some of
his drawer space we have some socks he
doesn't wear a socks he can't he can't
have socks that's rough yeah you can't
have anything really yeah what socks are
you wearing today uh this is nice those
are nice all right so black black that's
regular black wool socks you know that's
all not a big deal wow you thought you
were going into a problem
that's cool where's Waldo there's Waldo
what do you got I just got ankle socks
you're not showing a little ankle oh
[Applause]
you're an 1832
Leave Harlan
mcsee and she has tuberculosis
and palsy oh let's wrap this up all
right well anyway
um hey I hope you do get a chance to
check out the podcast sometime you how
will he hear this you laid-back slacker
yeah